have I ever advised anyone not to
crowdfund Yes um not to say that they
won't be successful in crowdfunding at
all but they aren't ready yet I mean the
biggest question is how much do you
think I can raise I don't know how big
is your online audience cuz you're going
to need them in order to raise money so
if you have never stepped foot into the
online space you really don't know how
that Twitter thing works or you don't
even have your own personal profile on
Facebook it's whoa okay you're not even
close to being ready to start a
Kickstarter campaign first you need to
get that first you need to get that
piece going first you need to be used to
connecting with an audience I'm not
saying you need millions of people but
you need a a core group of people um
because those are the ones who are going
to help you to spread out you're not
going to be able to spread word of mouth
all by yourself you're going to have to
have a group of people to do that and
it's going to be dependent on how active
those people are and how many are they
as to how much money you can raise you
know and and there is no figure if you
have 5,000 followers you should be ra
able to raise $30,000 I no I don't know
there are people who have 5,000
followers and only a 100 people gave
money so 30,000 is not going to you know
if they give $10 a piece you're going to
get a couple thousand you know you're
not there's also a huge correlation
between the number of people who are
lurkers and the people who actually will
take money out of their wallet and give
it to you and in presentations that I
give I show Freddy Wong as an example
he's you know on YouTube and is raised
two times um on on Kickstarter
significant amounts of money but if you
look at how many follow subscribers
Freddy Wong has on his YouTube channel
it's 4.7 million subscribers so you
would think oh he can raise Millions
only 10,000 of those people gave money
in any degree in his last Kickstarter so
it was very lot less than what he had as
his follower so we were talking about um
in this these recent Canadian Workshops
the
991 rule which Julie Giles talks about
she's from green hat digital and she
said 90% of your following are lurkers
they're people who are just watching
they never participate they've clicked
your page and of like and they've never
come back or they just see you in the
news feed and they never do anything
about it 9% of those people will retweet
you will put a thumbs up next to a
comment or leave a
comment um but they're not tight to you
you know they they participate but
they're not they aren't going to convert
only 1% of your supercore hardcore fans
will ever do anything to help you that
actually actively spread the word
support everything you do pay money to
go to your events show up if you have a
meet up that kind of thing so when
you're looking at your stats online and
you think that all all those 5,000
people are a sale you'll be very
disappointed when it when push comes to
shove about how many people actually
Pony up for the money so I would say
that if you haven't even gotten started
no no kind of uh crowdfunding effort
should be started um if you have gotten
started you're going to have to be
realistic it's better to go over your
goal than it is to not make your goal um
so set it realistically you know how
much do you really need to do what it is
and is is that the main goal behind this
campaign is it to raise money or is it
mainly to to build an audience to to
build up that participation and and
money is nice but that's not the main
idea behind this effort is to to grow
beyond your core because a campaign like
that usually helps you to to get more
people beyond the the people that you're
already engaged with because they help
you and there's an impetus to it because
there's a deadline as opposed to
constantly saying hey you know retweet
my stuff hey share my stuff you know
that that's just kind of an arbitrary
effort if you have a campaign where
there's a deadline and you're all
working towards some kind of you know
goal then there's reason to activate
those people in a certain time frame and
that's what a campaign is you know it's
it's a limited amount of time that
you're doing some effort um if if money
is your only thing then you're going to
have to be careful about how much you're
asking to raise because it depends on
how helpful the audience that you
already have is going to be to you I
thought about it um I felt I feel to
successful I I really believe in
crowdfunding in a lot of ways I feel for
it to be most successful you need to
have the support of everyone involved
and for me David's been Inc like Beyond
supportive like overwhelmingly
supportive of the project but he wasn't
a producer on the film um he you know he
would say this too he's not he wasn't
interested in the process he wanted to
let me go make it and I sort of felt to
run a successful crowdsourcing campaign
for it it would have needed his
involvement cuz I felt it would have
been sort of disingenuine to be the way
to run a successful campaign would have
been like hey Sedaris fans you want to
see a Sedaris movie and it felt what
sort of I didn't feel comfortable asking
him maybe he would have helped me and
done a video I'm not sure but I didn't
it felt wrong to ask him you know for me
and I felt without his support it felt
sort of wrong to run a campaign for it
now that there's a finished film if I
had we you know we've closed
distribution so I but if I was doing a
self-distribution I would consider it
now that there's a finished film and now
that I have interviews with David and
elements I can use
um with his permission of course but but
I feel like it's each each Project's its
own and some projects are meant to be
crowdfunded and and this one just wasn't
wasn't one of them I didn't feel like I
could engage the community in the right
way and also we had some actors attached
but they ended up not being the actors
in the final film and I felt like we
would have needed to utilize them but I
felt uncomfortable with that because I
didn't have a working relationship with
them yet and they were you know slightly
bigger names than what ended up in the
movie Just by the nature of whoever at
the time I cast them they weren't bigger
names and they got bigger names and got
too busy to be in the film and I ended
up with a cast could have only dreamed
of having anyway so I'm I'm thrilled
about that but it felt strange to bring
them involved it just didn't feel like I
could do it the right way and I feel
like when they look at the really
successful crowd crowd campaigns sure
there's some outliers that go into the
three and $400,000 but I really feel
like the most ambitious you really
should get you know is to expect is at
the most you know 100 you know I feel
like even the Canyons I think they ended
up going to like 130 but you have Paul
Shader and Brett Easton Ellis who each
have massive loyal decades long fan
bases and even then they pushed a lot on
that campaign and you know they hit
which is incredible amount of money but
that still wasn't enough for me to make
the film so I also felt
uncomfortable going out there and being
like give me $100,000 and maybe I'll be
able to find the other however much we
need it it it just felt wrong for this
project but I hope I can do something
one day that I can make cheaply enough
you know this movie had to be shot on
location it had 30 speaking Parts it had
you know a different location every day
all exteriors it just had things that
naturally made it expensive um and uh
but I hope to do something if I did
something small if I did a movie I could
shoot on my own and with minimal crew
and minimal locations and here in Los
Angeles I would I would totally consider
um doing crowd sourcing that
way so here's the deal everybody that I
talk to about crowdfunding right it's
called crowdfunding I my assertion is
that it should be called something else
because everybody thinks that the
maximum benefit of crowdfunding is of
course funding right get your money and
that's true that's a benefit and it's a
big benefit and it's important right but
there's also a wholly unappreciated sort
of dynamic that happens when you
crowdfund okay backing up the old way
the old way of Distributing the old way
of raising money before crowdfunding
existed you know thousands of days ago
right was uh you would have two ways
that you could get an audience to raise
their hand that they're a fan of your
right there was buy the DVD we're
talking about films now okay theyd
either buy the DVD or go to the theater
right and in those two ways uh it was
binary themselves of whether they would
raise their hand they would either buy
it or they would not buy it so you would
make your film for two years right and
you might tell your audience that uh
it's coming there's going to be a way
you can help us out just when the DVD
comes or inin theaters and go buy that
ticket or buy that DVD and then when it
happens they can either pay1 bucks for
the the ticket of the theater or not pay
or they can pay 20 bucks for the DVD or
not pay that's it so there are three
kinds of audience members all right
there is uh the first kind that is the
person who might have heard about the
film might have been interested in the
film maybe you had something on the web
maybe there was an ad and they're like
okay uh I think I will see that film but
just on the merits of the film what they
heard they'll go okay kind number one
kind number two is I don't know about
this film but I like Karen I like her
style I like her work I will see this
movie because I like that other thing
she did so they're fans of you and
they're not so sure about the movie but
they'll go because of you that's kind
too right then there's kind number three
which is I don't care what you do I'm
giving you money to do it I'm G to help
you do it I'm G to come do it I'm your
mother I'm your brother I'm your husband
I'm your son I'm you know whatever those
are your fanatical unconditional helpers
okay so you got one two and three right
in the old way you didn't know which was
which you couldn't get in touch you
couldn't differentiate your fan base you
didn't know some people just came
because they wanted to see the film some
people came because they saw your old
film and some people came because they
would do anything you tell them right so
in the new way um oh and finally those
three people all had one option they
could either buy it or not buy it so if
they kind of wanted to see it but
weren't sure and then they bought they
just paid 10 bucks if they really wanted
to see it they pay 10 bucks if they were
crazy about you and totally would see
anything you did they paid 10 bucks now
they might pay 10 bucks twice and buy
someone else a ticket or pay 10 times
and give someone else you know 100
people tickets or whatever you know buy
a bunch of DVDs for people but they only
could do that thing
right the revolution of crowdfunding and
again I think it should be called
something else is that now you can pull
all of those people all the way into
your process starting the moment you
think I should make a movie right and so
now you go out to your immediate
community and that of course includes
the number threes your mom your sister
your brother whatever it might include
your the number twos right which are
people who saw your other film so you
have a list it probably could include
number ones because through doing your
other things you have some people who
might be interested in the film you're
just thinking of right but now what
you're offering isn't hey I'm gonna make
this movie and someday pay me 10 bucks
to go see see it in theater or give me
20 bucks for a DVD now what you're
suddenly doing is you're unsealing all
of the value in the creation of the
artist artistic peace there's value all
the way from the moment you start
thinking about it to the moment you have
that DVD or or the ticket right and that
value exists in people's interest in the
subject their interest in you or they
just fanatical support of any of those
things the subject or you or you know or
your career so now what you can do is
when you have the idea you say hey I'm
thinking of making
a romance in Italy okay and it's going
to be about about two old people okay
they're you know senior citizens so I'm
really excited and so you start sharing
that in your social network now what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna say anybody who
wants to be involved in this way or that
way or the other way can by sharing with
me something you have which is maybe
money or time and in exchange I'm going
to give you the experience of creation
of that thing that you love everybody
who's a fan of romance movies everybody
who's a fan of Italy movies everybody
who's a fan of movies about senior
citizens and of course everyone who's a
fan of me right so you can give perks
based on the experience of creation so
you can say hey uh we're gonna have an
opportunity you can you can get in
communication with people about what
should the film be about I have this
idea and that idea you can start
communicating with all these people you
can start offering hey if you want your
name to be the name of the you know
hotel that the the the main characters
have dinner at it'll cost 150 bucks you
can come on the set you can hang out
people start to get excited and be
involved then what you start to do is
through the process of you also there's
also back up there's also ways that you
can offer an experience of meeting you
and meeting all the other people
involved maybe there's fans of the
actors maybe there's people you're going
to shoot on location in Italy maybe you
can say for this amount of money join us
on location in Florence and and you know
that cost you 2,000 bucks you charge
8,000 bucks maybe people really love you
and it has nothing to do with the movie
but they love you so you say hey I'm
going to cook you dinner and that's 600
bucks whatever pick a number the point
is that what it Taps into is human
beings desire to be involved in an
artistic Endeavor that takes years but
they don't have years they might be an
accountant or a lawyer or you know they
were a mom and they just made that
choice but they want to touch the film
making process and they want to touch
the people they're fans of and they can
pay for it and they will because before
all they could do was pay 10 bucks to go
to a theater right or 20 bucks to buy a
DVD but now
they can pay more and they can have
their their name involved they can be
involved with someone they love they can
be involved with the whole process of
movie making or specific kinds of movie
making and so what that does at the end
of the day after You' figured out all
those things that you can offer and as a
perk and get all these people involved
is you've moved people who are casually
interested the number ones into number
threes right where they are crazy about
you because they're invested in the film
they have their name on the hotel they
were on set they know all the actors
they know the guy who does services this
is their movie and so what happens is by
the time that you get to the end of
production which in the old days was
where you would start even trying to
find audience what do you have you have
all of these fans first of all who never
would have even been involved with you
then you have of those fans a giant
number of number ones which would have
been maybe I'll see the movie they're
shifted over to I'm a wild and rabid fan
of you like your mother and what happens
then the day that you release they're
all ready they're locked and loaded not
just to buy the ticket which they would
have done but to evangelize about the
film this is their film so suddenly you
don't just have your network you don't
just have your list from your old movie
you don't just have your actor's lists
you have all of the lists of all of the
people that ever got involved in the
whole two years of your pre-production
production post-production that have
been paying for the opportunity to do it
so you have a new Army of evangelists
for your film the day it comes out into
distribution that have paid you for the
opport opportunity to be there that is
the Revolutionary benefit of crowdfund
Gary I'm curious why you turned to
Kickstarter to self-publish your book
why not go a more traditional now it was
a process actually it was it was it was
an educational learning curve for
me it took me a while to figure out that
I didn't want a publisher that I did
want to self-publish and the relevant
reason primarily is I really wanted
Manifest Destiny I wanted to own my own
intellectual property and not give it up
and not be on a royalty basis with a
publisher who wasn't going to Market it
anyway I thought you know what I really
cuz I care deeply about what's in the
book it represents 25 years of my life
and I've always been in love with the
storytellers with the creatives and I
want to get this information out so I
thought if I own it I'm more free to do
that in more innovative ways so number
one I thought I'm going to self-publish
the Second Step was then how do you
self-publish it's a very fast shifting
landscape this world of publishing it
it's it's every day it's it's changing
by the hour and I I thought about I
thought okay I I've decided some things
that are good for me and there's a lot
of moving parts so I thought okay I'm
going to hire layout designers and
people to e format it and book cover
design it and I'm going to hire a
printer and order a certain book run and
on and on it there's a long laundry list
right I thought you know what if I do
all that that's great I'll have a
beautiful book and no audience and I
have to start from from
zero then I just then I thought I
started these conversations asking
people about crowdsourcing crowdfunding
in particular about Indiegogo about
Kickstarter and I realized Kickstarter
really was a phenomenal opportunity not
just because and and and and the least
of it was the
fundraising uh what was most interesting
to me was I get this period of time over
which to build a community I get to find
my brand evangelist I get to um really
put my message out almost serialize it
right over time and drive traffic from
all quarters from traditional media and
my database and other people to this
place called Kickstarter and it's very
Dynamic so this to me was the perfect
Community Building opportunity preed pre
you know just till the soil right how
much pre-planning did you do before you
launched the campaign and what sources
did you go to to gather information on
crowdfunding um well I have a uh my my
partner Morgan is very astute about
social strategy so she knew a fair
amount about it to begin with um I did
not I had to sort of study from the
beginning and but she brought me up to
speed fairly quickly and then we just
asked a lot of people who we'd seen
doing it that we we had contacts to um
and you just Google and you you know
today how do you learn you Google and
you ask people and you you get on social
media and you ask people um but it
became very clear that Kickstarter was
the platform that was the best fit for
us and uh and I'll be honest with you
you know it's it's not quite as neat and
clean as you would hope you use your
best judgment you go with your gut
because I think your gut is your best
guide for this kind of a social
experience um it's not a sales job you
can't you just it's got to be about
something something bigger than
that so it felt like if we just stay if
we really vulnerable and honest and
candid and and committed to what we're
doing and put that message out whether
it's the video or the copy or however we
present our choice of our ways of saying
thank you the perks that we put together
the people that we enrolled from my film
industry Community to be a part of that
if we created that as the ethos the
fabric of who we are and what we're
doing and we stayed true to that how bad
could we fail so that's how we began was
just sort of seated the pants and we've
learned so much every week and it's only
been two weeks into the campaign we've
learned so much well it looks like what
you're almost 80% funded or something we
we're we're just 90% funded and we're
about halfway through uh and now we just
did a Twitter tweeton today and we're
getting some traditional media to drive
traffic to it over the coming 10 days or
week
um and I I think we're learning how to
um not sustain energy but actually build
it and create a bigger conversation and
bring more invite more people in and
what's interesting is how much people
are ready to say
yes people really like to be part of
this kind of open conversation about
something they deeply care about and not
they don't deeply care about it because
it's necessarily screenwriting and
they're not a screenwriter it's about
creativity it's about seeing people
realize in this case maybe it's even and
seeing me realize a dream of
mine there's something that really tugs
at people about that and it's
cool you know what it's it's it's one of
those things you don't want to go back
to the well very often and I know
because when I did it and when you guys
did your good by promise the first
campaign we we were like way in the
beginning of of the whole phenomena
where people were really really
interested and giving us attention from
a lot of film blog sites and people just
Dona because of the novelty of it they
wanted to see it succeed but now again
in 2013 there's one every day from
somebody new and somebody you like
somebody you know and it's just hard to
to keep up and try to you know support
everyone uh I think I if I were to do it
it wouldn't be for any significant
amount it it's obviously nowadays it's a
marketing tool you see a lot of people
doing it that get noticed in film
festival programmers say they actually
scour the crowdfunding websites as well
so if I were to do it it'd be something
for just you know a smaller nominal
thing where I know I can make it but
it's mainly just to market the whatever
project I'm I'm working on and that's
probably the only time I would unless of
course you never say never you know the
situation comes up like this is the only
way and I'm going to give it a shot and
you know and you think it's been enough
time between projects where you have
enough a new fan base where it's not the
same old people then you know never say
never work you were able to raised
75,000 on Kickstarter in 3 days uh for
your space command project what was your
strategy when you launched this campaign
and then what did you find worked and
what did you find did not work MH well
um you know I've sold over 100 scripts
all of the studios and the networks and
uh in those cases I didn't have to raise
the money for instance when I was a
producer on sliders we had a 22 episode
order our budget was 1.3 million per
episode I didn't have to raise that
money so although I knew I could run
write and I know I can write and direct
and produce I'd never raised funds
before I didn't know if I would succeed
so the first thing I did was I treated
it as a as something new I had to learn
and I spent several months talking to
people learning how to do it building a
team uh shooting the video and really
putting effort into the video because
that would be uh you know what I'd be
using to show I could do the project and
uh but I didn't know if it would work I
didn't know if I could raise money at
all and now we're up to 158,000 we still
have um several week you know a number
of weeks ago we're going to be having a
panel at ComiCon so there's we're 158 is
not our final number by any means and um
so so what I basically did was I
realized I had to treat it with respect
and uh but I welcomed that I welcomed
learning a new thing but I had no
assumption that I would succeed and
going in with that attitude actually was
very helpful because then it
became uh a continual learning process
and uh and and the main thing I also
knew was that you had to be in direct
communication day by day with your
backers with your audience you couldn't
just it's not pushing the big red button
and then you know walking away that
that's I think why a lot of people F did
you research other campaigns what was
your sort of due
diligence yeah well fortunately I run a
round table of writers and directors and
actors and producers and we meet every
Thursday and we've been doing that for
19 years and it's several thousand
people and so I put out the word on to
my table saying if anyone knows about
Kickstarter please send me information
so I got a lot of response and so I
started researching successful campaigns
like double fine and some of the things
Neil Gaiman was doing and and then
ultimately Neil um uh showed me the
campaign that his wife Amanda Palmer was
doing and so I was learning from that
and uh and then just kind of course
correcting as I went and some things you
do uh don't work and some things you do
work and uh and then also you build a
team and so when show someone shows up
who wants to help first of all you find
out what their skills are and then you
say okay well let's see if they're
actually going to do it rather than just
talk about doing it and uh and what's
really also amazing is how fast
everything is there's instantaneous
response and so uh it could be a 24/7
job if you let it but you also have to
not get exhausted because you have to
keep a clear head to be able to do your
job how much time went into pre-planning
uh a couple months two or three months
yeah and uh and that was both shooting
the video and also just you know reading
up on Kickstarter talking to people
learning and uh um but also we actually
launched about a month later than we
intended simp because we had to do make
some further tweaks and we were we
finding the project because also that's
the other part of it you're also working
on the project as well the the the
series of films and you're developing
the concept builds and grows and people
will give you input and then you so you
you're responsive to that it really is a
very direct U two-way conversation and
the video is excellent thanks and uh I'm
wondering how much time you put into
planning that because you have so many
elements in it you have the personal
element where we you and other people in
your Ensemble but then you also have the
fun stuff in the background and all of
the the other work that you've done well
it was it was um we put a couple months
in on on the video and uh part of it one
thing I recognized with Kickstarter that
was very very clear is that you have to
have the Personal Touch it's the person
the individual saying hi this is who I
am I really would like your help it's
usually one person whether it's double
fine or Amanda Palmer It's usually the
the um the one-on-one and fortunately I
was a commentator on Morning Edition for
3 years uh long ago and I've done a lot
of media interviews and so I'm very
comfortable um with that and I think
that helped but also in my campaign it
was me as a person but it was also this
is the body of work I've done and then
the third part is this is the team I've
I've assembled and it's an amazing team
and then it was the special effect shots
that we were generating fresh saying
this is what what we're doing is going
to look like so it wasn't just you can
look at our work from the past but
there's no Talent what we're going to do
now here's something very concrete that
we generated new specific to this
project and that was very important
because otherwise people are going to be
dubious but if you say okay look look at
this if you like this if you like these
effect shots if you like these actors uh
who are going to be casting then you get
a pretty good idea about what we're up
to how did you choose your
incentives that took a long time to in
terms of choosing the incentives we
looked at other campaigns we thought
about ourselves as as Geeks and we'd
like uh CU When I was a kid uh Star Trek
debut the original Star Trek and I was a
huge Star Trek fan and and they they
were very slow in terms of merchandising
products from Star Trek initially there
were very few and I longed for different
you know model kits and and action
figures and toy phasers and all that
stuff so I was just kind of thinking
about me as a fan and and what would
appeal to me and what would I like to
have and what would be interesting and
it was a mixture of several things
because I was thinking about the
different uh kind of people who would be
um pledging to space command and so
there would be the fans who were just
science fiction fans they they'd love to
be part of this and maybe get a space
command watch or space command jacket uh
then there were also the people who
might be visual effects people and maybe
they want to be part of the team or they
want to learn from what we're doing so
there's also the the howto aspect so I
actually posted something called the one
minute film school that's about how you
pitch a script how you you know write
write a movie how you direct a movie
with my friends and like yo Del Toro and
uh my Michael N directs Battle Star
Galactica in in these videos talking
about those things uh and then there's
another part of it that might be
aspiring actors who might want to be
part of the project so they might want
to walk on a walk- on role or a speaking
role um or there might be someone who
wants to have a producer credit and so
they can put money in and get a producer
credit so so I was thinking about the
different reasons that someone might be
interested and how they might want to
participate and those are different uh
sort of pie wedges of the whole of the
whole pie and so you have to be mindful
of that as well that's not one size fits
all what are the first few things that
someone needs to do before they
crowdfund good
question uh I guess
um investigation of the market first
it's
like look around what's going on what
projects are being successful what's
happening why they are successful what
other the people is doing uh look around
and see if there is any project that
similar to yours and and what's the best
way to you know when we started with the
c as I said we took all these projects
that inspired us and we took what was
best out of each one and put it together
and try to build our own model instead
of just fitting in what was what existed
at the
time uh so I think that's important to
you know uh research a little bit and
then I think it's important to be
prepared to be very very honest I think
that's one of the things that work
better in our projects like don't
oversell sell what you
have and and try to make what you have
really good but you know you need to be
sure that what you're doing is really
good and and and be honest what with
what you're doing be transparent I mean
don't hide anything just tell the you
know when when our investor our Co produ
Russian co- producer drop out we could
have just said nothing because we were
at risk that 5,000 people that had given
us money would you know freak out to
know that suddenly we had 130,000 years
less and that the film was at risk but
instead of just you know saying nothing
we we were very public and was said guys
we are on the same team help us out and
it worked and every time something like
that happened to us like you know some
things that went wrong or or some things
that we knew that people wer maybe some
people weren't going to like we were
like you know this is how it is this is
how we think and and it's the way it
goes and I think that's one of the most
important things to be prepared to be
honest I don't know if there's anything
else that I can advise to be prepared
to how much should someone have invested
in social media beforehand that goes
back to our question sort of which comes
first the chicken or the egg and how do
you stay
honest in doing that it seems like it's
almost hard in some ways to to build a a
campaign if you know that you're going
to or excuse me it seems like it's
almost difficult to to build a social
media Network a little bit before a
campaign if you know that it's it's
difficult and I I don't think it's
something you can pay for I mean you can
pay for a campaign or for social media
whatever analyst or or company and they
can they can help you but you know at
some point for example every again every
time a client comes to us and says you
know what we're going to do this social
media campaign and I want uh a CO and I
want you know all these tricks they use
to uh get traffic to the side we say you
know what we are not I mean we're not
for you go to somebody else because
that's not natural I mean it's not you
you of course you can build numbers but
they're just numbers that's what we've
been you know fighting with brands for
the last three years because all they
say is you only have uh 5,000 users
5,000 fans I say okay just take any page
that has 50,000 fans that will probably
you know it's just kind of easy to get
numbers so check that put a post and
let's see how many comments does it have
and it usually have you know 15 people
commenting 50 likes and we have 5,000
and you know we say something cool we
have 200 comments and 500 likes so it's
like that's our numbers so uh again it's
not about the amount it's about the
quality so you need to start from the
ground and start you know be like very
little at the beginning and I'm trying
to connect with people and trying to
grow grow it bigger but you need time
for that that's you know the worst thing
of this is like it took us 3 years to
build a community and it's not even
really big uh so you need to be prepared
to have time to build that you can't do
that in 30 days unless you're lucky you
know this happened to us it's like we
launched the project and then uh the
week after one of the biggest blogs in
Spain talk about us because they like
the project and that was huge suddenly a
thousand people were coming to our site
and and and all of them were talking
about us because they love the project
and you know that it it spreads but you
need to find something or be lucky
enough to have like a kickart something
that you know makes it big and from
there well it depends on how good you
are on making it bigger uh but it's
difficult it's difficult to when
something like that I mean as I said you
can't do something
viral it happens you can't prepare for
it you can do it you know have something
that might be but again try 100
different things and some of them might
go viral and and and give you the first
Kickstart well you mentioned it is work
I mean it's like having a full-time job
and then some what's your day like
knowing that you launched the campaign
was it two days ago or yeah I think two
or three days ago yeah okay so do you
have like a set like a checklist of what
you're doing every day to keep that that
drum yeah yeah I mean there's so much
work going on between uh the kickstarter
campaign and then the other fundraising
that we're doing for this project just
with investors and whatnot that don't
have even have time to create a proper
checklist you know every day we every
day we come in it's just kind of a Mad
scramble to kind of do what needs to get
done we know we need to update people we
know we know we need to kind of check to
see where we're at with Kickstarter um
I'm a little obsessive about and I check
maybe every hour or so maybe sometimes
more um and so you know the the obvious
things are you know making sure we're
tweeting it out at least once or twice a
day and not doing it in an annoying in
your- face kind of way um same with the
Facebook updates and you know Facebook
and Twitter alone there's multiple
accounts that we're managing between
like the company's Twitter account and
the film's account so yeah there's a lot
of kind of just social media building
Graphics that we'll know that we know
we'll need either that day or down the
road um so yeah just kind of a
roundabout answer um saying that we
don't know what we're doing half the
time and just kind of doing as much as
we possibly can to get the word out
every day yeah what determined um the
length of time you're were going to
choose for the campaign I believe it's
what 31 days I think it's 31 days 31
days uhhuh um and also the amount 33,000
33,000 yeah the the we came up with
33,000 as the goal in part because we
had to be realistic with what we could
raise
um given our Network given our our
history with crown funding like I just
wanted to make sure we're being
realistic uh and not overshooting it
because as we all know Kickstarter is
All or nothing and we don't want to lose
you know lose out um so that was one
consideration the other consideration
was what will be enough to get the ball
rolling on the film what's enough to to
develop the project fully and what's
enough to kind of to start um the the
production process and 33,000 was kind
of the magic number oh and the other
element of course is is um in factoring
in the cost to produce the perks and the
rewards and whatnot for for backers and
so yeah 33,000 33,000 was the the magic
number um to get the ball rolling on the
project and and what we realistically
thought we could raise and so you
decided to not go with like a 52 day
campaign you wanted it shorter I'm just
yeah I'm I can't I'm trying to remember
why we decided 31 days I mean we wanted
to we wanted to end the campaign on a
Friday like in the evening cuz everyone
says to end it on a Friday which is
often Payday for people and you know you
want to give enough time to people to
get home from their jobs get on their
email and exactly glass of wine oh yeah
glass of wine and get loose and you know
um how do you get the wallet exactly
yeah so I think I think it ends on
Friday like at 10:30 p.m. or something
like that oh that's great yeah um and
did you I mean research other campaigns
to see what you saw worked and yeah we
researched a lot of campaigns we
probably looked at about 100 different
campaigns we watched all their videos we
looked at their rewards their perk
structure um all the text on the actual
Kickstarter page and you know a lot of
it came down to kind of what felt good
to us and we kind of went with our gut
as far as as as a viewer as an audience
member as a fan what do we want to read
on these pages and what kinds of perks
would get us excited um so along the way
we're just constantly telling ourselves
let's put ourselves in their shoes what
do they want to see what do they need to
know what will excite them um and so
that that helped a lot yeah and what are
the
perks um the perks for our Kickstarter
campaign include some of the more common
things like you know exclusive updates
about the film at the $2 level and then
of course a copy of the DVD a download
of the film but then we came up with
some unique things like um Instagram uh
Polaroid coasters uh because this film
is going to be so visually driven and
hopefully cinematically kind of
beautiful we we wanted to kind of do
something having to do with photography
so yeah one of the perks is these cool
little uh in um these like Polaroid cup
coasters um you know postcards and
posters uh a dinner with myself and the
uh author of a book called in pursuit of
Silence which I'm sort of um so what has
sort of influenced this this film um and
so things like that yeah yeah that
sounds really cool
that's creative the the dinner and with
the author I like that yeah thanks and
another consideration was um because I
experienced this with our last
crowdfunding campaign like it's got to
be rewards that are relatively simple
for us to put together um one thing that
was a constant Thorn on our side with
the last crowdfunding campaign was this
photo book this elusive photo book that
we promised backers and it seemed like a
really cool idea cuz we had a
photographer on Set uh on every shoot
that we took in Haiti and so we had
these gorgeous photographs and we
thought cool you know let's do a photo
book how hard could it possibly be you
know it was just like it was just so it
was expensive it took just so much time
to design it um and it was just way more
work and money than than we anticipated
and it became a pretty big problem for
us here in the office just trying to get
that done on time and um ended up being
you know several months late but people
were happy when it finally came and then
was that Jess Jess Kaylor yeah K is our
photographer and she's brilliant I we we
wanted to Showcase those photos so badly
that's kind of what drove us to want to
do this photo book but we didn't realize
how much work it would be W yeah
beautiful photos I remember seeing yeah
I'll have to get you guys a copy of the
book before you guys leave yeah Sher
what what's the question you get asked
most
often um I think everybody is really
curious about audience audience building
and crowdfunding I get a lot of
questions about you know usually after a
campaign's already launched what which
sometimes is too late to be asking that
question often as well when you're
launching um uh going about to launch
your film and then you start asking
questions about the audience that's
totally backwards um that all these
questions really need to be started in
the very beginning of this you know when
you're making the film when you're
writing the script when you're thinking
about there should be in your mind who
who am I writing for who do I imagine
watching this movie that I'm writing I
would think that would make it easier a
little bit in the process that you're
you know maybe putting in in jokes or
you're uh being sure to include a
certain kind of information because you
know that's what your audience is going
to want to know if you don't have that
idea when you're
writing it continues to be a problem
throughout into distribution because
it's it remains vague you're not sure
who you're going after you're not sure
who's going to respond to this material
and it makes it that much harder because
you're putting on all your time and your
effort and your money into this without
a clear idea of how you're going to get
anything out of it um so you know that's
one of the big questions is audience and
the time to ask that is not we're in
post and now we're trying to figure it
out or we're about to raise money in
crowdfunding and we need to figure this
out it's when you're developing the idea
and to start with I ask who are you you
know what what are you interested in
what Drew you to this story why do you
feel compelled to tell it then where do
you hang out online where do you hang
out offline what do you read who do you
listen to all those aspects to starting
with with you makes it lots easier
because you know yourself you know
that's not hard to to identify um it's
when they start with these demographics
18 to 35 women you know that's a huge
huge desparate group they don't all love
the same things so thinking more along
the lines of interest and psychology and
what emotionally moves it really takes
you then out of an age group you're
really targeting then an interest group
a psychology that you want to find and
it's much easier to find those people
than when you're just targeting a blank
Age and and once you do once you have
identified your audience and you're sort
of ready to take that next step
um what are those next steps you know
where do you go from there well um I
have S of changed my thoughts about when
you should start this process of
audience engagement one I think that
artists should be doing that all the
time so in that way you are creating
your own identity in marketing speak it
would be brand I find filmmakers don't
like to use that word but I mean in
marketing that is what it is a brand is
your identity your personality so you
should be sharing that personality all
the time when you're online
professionally I don't mean what are you
having for breakfast
where you went on vacation with your
family you know deep dark secrets about
yourself I don't mean to to to make all
your private thoughts known and your
privacy um given up but from a
professional standpoint what drives you
what motivates you um and and start you
can start today you know with sharing
that of figuring of of pulling people
toward you who are of that same mindset
who are compelled by the same thing
you're compelled with um a great book
that I read over
was called start with Y it's by Simon
cynic um and he uh says people don't buy
what you do they buy why you do it so
you should always be showing people your
why you know you should always start
from thinking how does this show why I
do what I do and those same people who
are compelled to do to think that way or
do those things or are motivated by the
same things that you are get drawn to
you now if you're a negative person and
I've seen this happen a lot online where
people are very cutting and they cut
other people down and they always have
really negative things to say and then
they get surprised when negativity
starts coming back at them you know on
their sites in their comments on their
blogs on their Facebook page lots of
negative comments it's what what you're
putting out in the world is what is
coming back into you what's attracted to
you so if you don't want that then don't
be that don't show that um of yourself
online um but so that's what you start
to begin with now if you have a project
during the time when you're in
production when you're writing and
you're in production you're you're
stockpiling you're collecting you're
looking for all the assets that you're
going to be able to use or that you can
use to create more material for later
but hold off on the online engagement
opening up your social channels till
you're about six months from your
Premiere because in six months you can
keep the motivation up you can keep the
momentum you can release new things and
six months is not a terrible burden and
the audience can stay with you for that
long if you're 2 years or 3 years to
making a film you're not going to be
able to keep up that Project Specific um
content release for very long it's just
it will be too draining for you you'll
run out of ideas and the audience will
get bored you know they they when is
this thing happening when is this thing
coming out they kind of do expect that
when they hear about it it's soon going
to be released and they'll be able to
see it so they can wait about 6 months
or about four months but they can't wait
for indefinite period of time so when
you're thinking about project wise for a
long time you're going to be collecting
and thinking about how you're going to
release and then when you get into post
and when you see okay we're about 6
months from when it doesn't have to be a
firm date you know you don't have to
know if you're doing it from a festival
you won't know if you're going to get in
but but you know around October or
around January it'll be ready and we
will be looking to have the premiere
then get started then start um showing
your your project off and getting
interest and getting people then you're
maintaining your pages and you're
cultivating an audience for the
project how many days into the campaign
are we uh 54 right
now3 5 days in or something like that 5
days in and we've got 54 days left uh uh
it's nerve-wracking yeah it is it's very
nerve-wracking but we're going to work
as hard as we can to you know uh reach
the public with this project as best as
we can uh we're going to Tweet it until
my fingers fall off I'm going to email
it and send it out email I haven't slept
in B we haven't slept we just been
online there all night just sending it
to people trying to reach reach reach a
lot of people out there so they can try
to help us support this project yeah
we're getting very good responses a lot
of people really like the project and uh
uh they're really like the videos and uh
they they're inspired by it too the
thing is though I I I'm learning though
people are they gravitate to the child
abduction human trafficking in this
country too so they're like I didn't
know that and I have a supplementary
video that gives a lot of statistics
about those subjects and uh when people
see that I get I'm getting a lot of
emails and uh uh tweets back about I
didn't know that it was really happening
here and then that just gives me more
and more fuel and lets me know that this
you know film needs to be made so that
people can be more aware of it is it
anybody resonating with the characters
trying to change the course that they
were once on and make a new life or is
that not totally revealed not totally
revealed um that's the to me I think
that's uh more the intricacies of the
story and for me to sum it up the the
real cause for me though it's a great
story but the real cause for me is the
child abduction human trafficking you
know in the country I I hope people are
really aware of that and and and and uh
you know become aware that that is
something that's happening here and uh
you know and you know I hope that
inspires people to really uh you get
behind the cause but uh the kickstar has
been going really good um we've got a
long way to go but you know we're still
going to keep pushing it and getting it
out there and we we hope people uh you
know help us get this film made and so
what are the the ground rules you have
like do you have a daily checklist of
what you do or just you just know
everyday's go hit the ground run it's
just me and him so it's hard some some
people some people have like a team of
like 20 people before the kick start
just me and him so I got the the the
morning routine I go online and uh he
also he also he also does the same thing
so we do it in the morning and at night
so we barely sleep we we on it all the
time we take like breaks here and there
cuz sometime you get discouraged wow I
just send it like a thousand emails I
don't it's still not moving you know
what I mean and then uh oh yeah somebody
plays I'm okay we're good let's keep
going let's keep going it doesn't take
much to keep us going you know all I
need is a good tweet you retweet me I'm
still going I'm not going to quit if you
retweet me I'll take the little things
for now but yeah we work in shifts and
you know it's we take our breaks you
know you CU you put in hours doing that
you get kind of loopy uh looking at the
screen so much so you know take a break
and you know get a cup of coffee go at
it again you know uh in the end is you
know it's just try to reach as many
people you know as we can I think we
have too we got a lot of people like
maybe like uh that that like like the
page or they just send us a message oh
we like we like the project but they
don't they don't pledge but we get a lot
of them that that like the project and
stuff like that so we we reaching some
of them we doing we're doing good so far
the time frame to we on 5 days so we're
doing good so far so what are some of
the highs and some of the lows what what
what things are are the ones where you
go and then takes you back up again
besides the tweets okay uh it just film
making in general or the kickstarter
promotion for the kickstar keep
ourselves going we keep ourselves going
so yeah it's literally like and luckily
it's we're never at a point where we're
both down so it's always he'll call me 4
in the morning yo you good and I'll call
him again oh you good we call him we
call each other every like 2 three hours
we call each other I I would I would
definitely say the low for me is if you
get back somebody like uh uh you know
you you you get some negatives every
once in a while like oh you know I don't
know you so don't send me tweets and
stuff like that you get you get stuff
like that but then uh you know you hit a
couple people later and somebody
retweets me and I'm say hey thank you
and that's enough for me to keep going
because not everybody shares the same
mentality and you know I just feed off
of that you know you're going to have
negativity and things like that but you
you have to again here comes the thick
skin you just let it roll off and you
keep on going you know so you're your
own support system to you yeah
absolutely absolutely and it works cuz
we're both stubborn
so both extremely stubborn we won't quit
we won't quit we're going to find some
way to get through it you know what I
mean like my mom said somebody blocks
you try to break the door go through it
so that's how we that's how we doing
yeah
yeah you know I find it very interesting
that that you two said
that um you knew this $28,000 goal was
kind of like wow this was at the high
end of the spectrum you know and and you
said that you too kind of like going
after the impossible and sort of like
really pushing it um Can can we talk
about setting setting that particular
number goal cuz I I think that's that's
often one of the things that everyone
sort of struggles with it's like okay I
think I want to make this project and I
think I'm going to want to try to try
crowdfunding and setting that goal can
be so tricky because you just don't know
you don't you don't know how to size it
up so can you talk about the $20,000
goal and yeah uh so I think our original
plan um was to do a second season of our
web series and when we ran the numbers
for that we were going to originally run
a crowdfunding campaign for that we were
going to set that uh at maybe 10 to 12
and you know when looking at the numbers
of what what we expected and hope to get
where where we could reach um we thought
we thought that was doable um then we
decided to to change it up do it as a
feature um and so nothing as far as our
resources change but but the budget
change and so we we set it at a at the
minimum point that we could do
production of the future so that's how
that's how we came to um that number so
that doesn't necessarily even cover all
of prod but it covers enough um that we
could still find a way to get production
um production route uh get it in the can
so that's how we came up with that
number and I think you know like he said
you know our original thought was okay
maybe 10,000 for for the the second
season of the web series and you know
when we did the first one we didn't have
any budget at all I mean we had a camera
and a lot of interested people and a lot
of drive and and you know that's about
it and you know when we looked at our
final product we were we were proud of
the experience and that we had done it
and we had spent so many countless hours
doing it but you know getting to do it a
second time I mean that's a really
unique opportunity to be able to work
with the same people and kind of see
them grow having seen them grow over the
year and like what else they're bringing
to the table and even myself like I'm
I'm kind of new at this you know cuz he
he's always been doing this but it's not
until recently that you know his goals
became my goals as well and so you know
I I I am um I had a lot more to bring
with myself as well so you know we
talked about a lower number but it's
like that's not we we didn't want to
make the same mistake as the first time
you know we're we're just having a very
ambitious project where you can't get it
reasonably shot and it's not what it
looks like or it's not what you want it
to look like and then so I think you
know we had to like that was actually
the minimum number that we would need
and you know we could supplement the
rest with you know our own income or you
know take a loan here and there or
whatever but you know we we can make up
that small difference that we needed to
get to our to our full budget but um but
any lower than that you know if we had
set at 25 or if we had set it at 10 I
mean we're still looking at you know
trying to raise another 1015 and and you
know who knows where that would have put
us in the end and and our goal with this
film was to to make a good film um like
she said with the first season of the
web series you know we had no budget we
uh we had no uh not a lot of production
value um and we didn't want to make
another we didn't want to make another
project that was good given the
resources we just wanted to make one
that was good period um not like well
that was good considering what you
didn't have or that was good considering
this or that or that just you know
something that was good so you're
preparing to launch a crowdfunding
campaign yes in February March to um to
give us a nice little production budget
for uh season 2 of laps so what's some
of your prep work that you're
doing uh it's going to going to be well
the biggest thing is like trying to
figure out what are these rewards you
know that's such a big thing because
that's that's um the thing that's
enticing people to donate you know what
what are they getting out of it and um
I'm actually uh I'm I'm gearing I'm I'm
compiling a list but I don't have like a
set list yet of things some of them are
like um uh we did a commentary for
season one that I never released so and
it's with it's honestly so long ago that
I don't remember doing this remember me
art or me you me and Art Hall who is not
here right now sitting next to me
manifestation I'm actually rhe in a
mask I would have gotten away with it
too yeah all right so yeah we all sat
around we all sat around we Matt Lewis
was there where where we record this at
R's apartment you're right was there
some wine involved what probably chance
I guarantee actually there were usually
whenever also whenever I do commentary
that's usually how it go you always hear
a crack of a beer can or of a Miller
time it's Miller time she knows me yeah
so we uh so we did that and I'd like to
put that out as like a one of the
rewards cuz it's really
funny it's probably I'm got to guess
maybe it's just funny to us but no I'm
just kidding no t-shirts not doing
t-shirt I would like to do doing
t-shirts yeah because the show the show
is such a workout you know like going to
the track kind of thing it'd be cool to
have like a tank top or something you
know not you know fanny pack fanny pack
right to keep the phone and the
cigarettes yeah exactly all the things
you need when you work out you need the
wide one for the cigars you know right
exactly like a little hip humidor yeah
um that's a good idea though it's like
well maybe flask maybe we could have
DVDs of the first season yeah you know
all bonus featur the audition t tapes I
think
is interesting he doesn't like that no
one likes audition tapes okay all right
I don't no actors like well maybe some
actors like their own audition tapes and
if they do I'm a little leery about a
little leery about that um so yeah I'm
I'm getting that stuff together and then
uh in a couple weeks we're we're going
to shoot the like the the pitch video oh
great okay and are you having everybody
involved and yeah you'll narrate it or
uh I'll probably sort of like the video
Journal I'll intro it but um we'll shoot
it back at the track and I'd like to
have all the roles cast by then so that
we can have the entire cast there and
just be like you know this is what we're
this is our team of actors and talent
that uh are going to bring season two to
life kind of thing and then ask for
money are you doing research on what
campaign videos sort of strike a court
in you yeah like did you have any
examples of I know II was a great
campaign video II J Town yeah she did a
great yeah and there was also
um well I I do like um um God what's
that guy that we were just talking
about the feature film that he's been
working on for years oh oh the guy from
No No Film School oh c yeah cou did such
an amazing job with this video
absolutely yeah I mean the tricks that
he used in that video was really cool I
don't know what I'm going to pull that
but you know he had a really good pitch
and that's what this is going to come
down to is do you have a compelling
pitch and uh yeah I'm looking at other
campaigns and it's not like I'm using
just one for like an example I'm looking
at several and then like taking piece by
piece and making notes kind of thing so
I wish I had more examples but it's more
just as I go I'm like oh that's pretty
cool that's pretty cool and I tuck it
away and and then how have you
determined how much you're going to ask
for one thing we've seen recently is
that people are really going for these
high amounts right and it it's been it's
been harder these days to get them I
think people are the honeymoon period is
kind of over for crowdfunding I think
it's it's a little tougher now right and
uh there's also a huge debate between
Indiegogo and Kickstarter M which I'm
still debating okay yeah um but I'm
going to I'm going to keep it low you
know um I know that I can fall back back
on some you know of my own personal
money but also uh some friends here in
La that have camera equipment that I
would like to you know they've already
said yeah you can go and use it so I'm
keeping the budget low it's mostly for
locations because it's such a bigger
story you know yeah yeah the locations
are
uh that's going to be a big piece of it
I want to be able to have the money for
food and whatever you know lighting is a
big thing too so Arts place that's true
uh we well if there's a way to fake it
into a two bedroom apartment absolutely
I'm I'm open to it I've I have I've did
various sure various Apartments I've
lived in I've always allowed people to
film it and like I I'm like oh sure of
course halfway through I'm like damn it
why did I say yes to this cuz you know
it's a little woring dervish comes into
your apartment everything just gets all
over but of course no we'll make it work
you know but yeah the world is much
bigger but I think it's going to
strongly benefit us so yeah so I'm not
going to shoot for the I'm going for
$100,000 budget I'm going for like a
3500 and yeah like pretty modest I mean
it's really modest for what I made
season one on like 20
bucks maybe plus CR Services yeah yeah
like however much bottles of water and
donuts yeah Taco about tacos for
everybody Taco about tacos and lots of
starches and carbs which is perfect for
somebody that's trying to lose weight
yeah thank
you and then you're not planning on
going on any vacations or anything
during during the campaign we talked
about earlier no not at all no weddings
or anything no I'm just going to I mean
I'm going to Vegas for a couple days in
April but that's pretty much it so yeah
you can't go toas okay I guess I'm not
going toas anym you can tweet
from tweet from Vegas I will send a
picture of me at Caesar Circus Circus I
think has good
Wi-Fi well you have the LTE network
that's true we do right we have plans so
what else have you noticed from
crowdfunding campaigns that you like
what what are the some of the things
that you've seen that have really worked
and then some that haven't the over budg
is I feel like a big one um but not
having a good pitch video to me I feel
like is the ones I've seen I'm like I
would never donate to that cu the video
wasn't good whether it was a production
value or just the pitch wasn't good I
just didn't feel like it was a
compelling enough story or you know that
kind of stuff so I really want to make
sure I'm good with that do you think
people view that as okay if the pitch
video is bad then what's the actual
production going to look like is this a
representation of their work well I mean
that's the way I take it I don't feel
that just a pitch video is enough I feel
that people are buying not just a reward
like a DVD or t-shirt or chance for a
sign script or something they're they're
trying to become a part of a process
that they normally wouldn't be so invite
them along on that Journey like you know
show them where you're coming from where
you want to go like the good things the
bad things that happened so keep them in
the loop and that's what I've seen on
the successful ones I've only followed
one or two I'm very loose I hardly ever
looked but I know one of them was um
kind of an easy sell I forgot the guy's
name but he was one of these video game
developers in the 90s who did a lot of
point-and-click Adventures like day the
tacal and stuff like that and he wanted
to make a throwback point and click game
for all the people who reminisce like me
and all those other people and he's said
$100,000 what I need to fully design an
engineer and develop this this program
and he would make videos if not weekly
than daily to talk about progress and
all the artwork and everything he made
three or
$400,000 because people were so on board
with you know that part of it is again
the subject matter of you know you're
you're playing on the Nostalgia of the
game you know culture from that era but
he took you on a ride and showed you how
did things work and that I think is
really the big thing that's why it's you
need a marketing team or someone
full-time because takes a lot to
consistently update and send messages
and video and then edit and all that
stuff so that's what I think is really
the big indicator or big thing to help
and for me the video journals is is is
trying to do that mhm and do you think
you'll do a shorter campaign 30 days or
longer um I'm I'm right now I'm on 30
yeah what what makes you like that date
that 30-day t uh I don't know it's a
good number you it's just a month and
you try it out if it the other thing too
is I know that there's the the chance of
failure you don't make it in 30 days you
know so then we need to to do another
campaign or that's true you have a fall
back instead of putting it all in 160
day campaign I guess yeah yeah because
I'm uh I'm not doing this campaign to be
like uh I'm I'm GNA you know please
donate and we might shoot in a year it's
like I'm doing this campaign please
donate we're shooting in May you know uh
we're ready to go well you're not going
to be able to sleep if it's not exactly
true
I I mean yeah you like to do things
quite a while and that's great I I like
to have things ready like um I didn't
start I didn't start try to I I didn't
try to cast lap season one without the
script being in a good
place you know I feel like you need to
have confidence in in uh you know
someone's going to come onto your team
you got to have a basis you know you got
to have that that thing is that's going
to motivate people to be like no I want
to work on that and if and that requires
me to have my stuff in line have it in
check and ready you
know Michael how would you compare and
contrast Kickstarter to Indiegogo and
would you give the edge to
Indiegogo uh they're very different now
Kickstarter and Indiegogo I mean when
they first started it was kind of like
hey there's this new platform for funny
movies and what not I think through time
they've kind of separated a lot uh
Kickstarter obviously is probably a
little more mainstream I just from
people I know uh talking to them they
they they feel a little more comfortable
not So Much Anymore with Kickstarter
just because it's known a little more on
the press and all that I honestly I I
don't know their goals or where they're
going but I feel like they're really
separating and kick and Indiegogo is
kind of the
the place where you go where you're you
know the Indie spirit I should say is
alive in Indiegogo abut um and it's and
socially too they do a lot of social
campaigns that that work well
Kickstarter seems much more now like I
say it's pre-sales now they don't really
I don't know they don't do so much
pre-sell in movies anymore but it's kind
of it's kind of going I know the
kickstarter people probably don't like
that because they' sent messages and all
that like you you know we're a donation
based site but I think the because
because of kickstarter's mainstream
success they've attracted you know
certain compan they attracted like the
video
games uh industrial design type
companies which aren't they're so
already fully funded they're not like a
little movie where it's like hey we're
going to go shoot this little movie and
hopefully it'll turn out good and it's
just us and we're kind of artists um not
that video game people aren't artists by
any means but you know it's it's it's in
their business plan almost in a way as
where indigogo still is uh kind of
independent and and you know we need
your money to make this movie whereas
the other things are kind of we oh yeah
we just want to cut off some of our
losses before we release I video game or
whatnot so but they both have uh good
and valid points I would probably our
docs are a little more mainstream so I
think Kickstarter is a little better way
to go um for that but then the movies we
do are so for such a limited audience
that it's like yeah you know and it's
it's the movies uh such as the one we're
doing now is it's all people just doing
the movie because they want to do the
movie you know there's no other real
goal like you know all the actors kind
of really like the concept and they want
to do the movie because of the concept
over uh any kind of success they see in
the future well who's the audience for
love touch hate
what do you envision it's such a tough
answer to say who the audience for the
movie is because it's a very I think on
the on the the actual movie is very I
think audience friendly it's a it's a
Bittersweet comedy there's elements of
Comedy it's a fatherson story which we
don't really talk about in the campaign
because it's just too much to put in the
little video um the initial conceits of
the movie could be mainstream but it
could be very very Indie and
my take on it is a very very Indie take
because I'm just I'm exploring something
and it's not the not the uh the way the
Hollywood movie would probably be in
terms of structure um so it's a kind of
a tough thing to say I think you know
the audience is pretty pretty small but
the people who actually show up to watch
the movie would probably like it a lot
that makes
sense well I think number one the most
important thing is to start from a place
of passion I think uh I could probably I
would not have had a successful
Kickstarter campaign we wouldn't have
had a successful Kickstarter campaign if
we weren't truly 100% passionate about
the film because your passion I think
will come through in any type of
promotion you do video to me seems like
the biggest no-brainer of all time for
filmmakers but a lot you know a lot of
filmmakers for whatever reason either
they're
gunshy31 or you know what all the all
the typical you know ways that people
like to think of you know crazy
filmmakers the truth is if you care
enough about your project to you know
sweat Blood and Tears to get it done you
should care enough to tell people why
and I think that if you start from a
place of honesty and passion in however
you're communicating all you'll already
be ahead of the pack um I think the
mistake that a lot I see a lot of Indie
filmmakers make when they start making
some sort of tape is that they they'll
try to maybe like ape or copy uh a
different campaign that was
successful but that may be completely
inappropriate for what it is they're
doing and more often than not you watch
a filmmaker and you go who cares you
know I you know I I don't care I bet you
a lot of filmmakers when they watch that
own tape that probably don't it probably
doesn't move them but I think if you
again if you step from a place of
honesty and and you you create something
that's as real as the movie you made in
the first place something as personal
and cool and quirky and interesting as
your own work people are going to
respond and I mean listen I'm a big sap
but I when I watch our Kickstarter video
I still tear up and you know yes part of
it is because I have to admit that I
look that Goofy on camera but part of it
is because I I really I really do it the
journey meant so much to us that it was
impossible not to be passionate when we
talked about it so I think my first tip
would be start from a place of honesty
and passion what's your second tip I'm
getting it in order I I I know what it
is I know what my second tip is but go
ahead I thought you might want want to
expand um expand on the passion no I
absolutely agree we
um
um we're working with some filmmakers
now who are uh doing a documentary
called Journey Through Fire and um they
actually came and and one of the video
things that they're doing which I
thought was really nice is they're uh
talking to different filmmakers and
having them almost pitched the film
where you know what I mean what is it
that inspired them about about the film
or what is it that inspires them about
the project which I think again to the
passion that it's not just the
filmmaker's passion but the show that
the film has inspired a passionate
response in others I think definitely
helps in terms of having you know
testimonials you know within the pitch
video which is not something we did but
I saw them doing it um just recently
they're working did different kinds of
testimonials right but you know for them
it really um I mean they're still still
in the in the in the editing process
they don't have their film finished yet
you know we saw rough cuts and little
bits and pieces and you know found out
about the stories and all of that but um
you know again it's speaking to the
passion it's just what's your passion if
you know if I'm an audience member and
you know you're the filmmaker of course
you're passionate about your project but
to see somebody else get passionate
about your project who's not necessarily
connected to it in any way that's
intriguing and then I go oh you know
what what is in your project that's s
their passion then that may also then
spark mine and I think one one idea that
you're hitting on there that I do think
is important if you're lucky enough to
have it is social proof you know um
basically proof that there is a love of
your project outside your own love you
know because of course you love it you
wouldn't have you know spent all your
money and all your time making it we
were so lucky to that when we played our
initial festivals that we were not only
winning but we were getting standing
ovations and and we we brought cameras
with with us to the screenings in hopes
of gathering some type of audience
reaction it far exceeded our
expectations but being able to show
people our film is receiving One
Standing Ovation after another and
people in the lobby are unable to
contain themselves and they're and
they're they're crying and talking about
the film and this is what real people
are saying about the movie I think lent
a lot of credibility and it also made
people feel good about supporting the
film whether it was donating or watching
or deciding to buy a ticket it's like
well there's other people in the world
being moved by this movie that only say
not only says to me that it's good it
also says to me this is something I want
to be a part of you know am I missing
out by not seeing this film is is it you
know would my life you know maybe be
touched like that person's life was
touched if I took the time to go see it
or or not not all movies are need to be
touching it could be a comedy you know
am I going to have that much fun at the
movies you know is is it worth me going
to escape for a few hours so I do think
that if you can hint at Social proof in
any kind of pitch you do for I for
anything just proving that that there's
there's a more Universal you know
attractiveness to your project I do
think that will help um the next point
that I think is is is really important
and I think this speaks
to again it doesn't matter if you're
making a movie if you're selling widgets
you know if you're you're trying to get
book to give speeches whatever I think
you have to know your audience you know
it's really important to know that
audience and to speak to them um and and
I don't that that necessarily mean a lot
of people will go oh well who's your
audience and then they'll automatically
start breaking it down into
demographics I don't think that
necessarily works as well for
independent filmmakers I mean yes it's
important to know in general you know
this movie is going to appeal to men
more than women or or vice versa but a
lot of times Indie filmmakers fall into
this weird in between place because
we're making something that's different
and it doesn't necessarily fit one
specific mold so I think you want to
figure out how to appeal to certain
pieces of everybody I mean I think we
all have you know in the case of dying
to do Letterman I think we all have an
underdog Spirit no matter who you are no
matter if you're a man or woman no
matter what age you are all of us at
some point in our lives have been the
underdog or rooted for an underdog and
that was something we worked really hard
to tap into when we you know when we
reached out and it was not only
reflected in our video which very
clearly said no one wanted us to make
this movie which was true people said it
you know it was a horrible idea to shoot
the film people thought we were crazy to
invest our money in it I mean we we were
underdogs Steve's story is a major
Underdog Story So by saying to people
you know look we're underdogs be part of
our Underdog Story I think that help
them relate to the movie I think if you
can find something that's Universal in
your film and be and think of that as
your demographic what's my demographic
it's underdogs we all have a little
piece of the underdog you know so in a
way it makes it easier to focus your
message like like you're tapping into
that Essence as opposed to I'm just
going for the you know 18 to 39y old
male which probably if you're an
independent filmmaker you probably don't
fit a category quite so sharply unless
you set out to make a commercial film
which is a whole different business plan
alog together so one we
applaud what's
that oh I I listen I I I I think yes
well that's that's a whole side note I
think unfortunately I think a lot of
independent filmmakers get lumped into
well you can only make one kind of movie
which is not true an independent
filmmaker is a person that goes and
makes a movie with their own money
because no one else will pay for it you
know I think that if someone went out
and they did their independent version
of Armageddon God bless him I'd support
him 100% I do think there's a bias
against you know young aspiring
filmmakers who tend to make stuff that
appeals to the masses as opposed to
Niche audiences so for the record I
completely support anybody and applaud
anybody who who has the gumption The
Finisher movie and if your movie happens
to be Armageddon or a horror movie or a
comedy and it doesn't fit your typical
you know Festival Festival model it's I
I don't think people should care I think
you should be applauded for finishing
your film in the first place so that's
that's a whole rant for another
day do you think that crowdfunding is
hurting or even ruining social
media wow that's a really really hard
question uh explain it to me a little
bit more I mean what do you mean well it
seems like you know it's great to follow
people it's great to be supportive of
what they're doing but when you feel
that they've friended you or they've
followed you and they're singing your
praises and then a week later they let
you know about their crowdfunding
campaign it almost feels as if social
media has now become more about um
marketing instead of being social okay
um yes the answer is yes and let me give
you an example and I think this is a
huge mistake from people making projects
you know you can't push it you I mean
it's stupid to ask people for money we
have never done that in 3 years actually
uh our friends you know it's like first
thing you do when you make a crowfunding
campaign is just harass your friends
like hey vote me give me money share
this what I mean even with my friends I
tell them it's like dude uh why let me
Discover it let me I mean and I'm not
going to like it because it's you I'm
going to like it because I like it so
let me Discover it let me let me just
you know give me the opportunity to
watch it but don't ask me to vote you or
to give you money because you are you
and that's a huge mistake that can kill
a project so you know we we never push
it that way we just put the project
online and it was funny because our
friends you know it took like two years
for them to give us money you know two
years when we had been a success in
Spain we've been in in every media and
everything they decided to put money and
you know it was am amazing because at
that point I felt that that the project
was a success you know when even my
friends that you were tired of listening
listening me talk about the project they
decided to get in uh so I think it's
important not to push it and and you
know have a different idea of what
social is and and what Crow funding is
like make friends and that's okay and
they're going to help you probably to
you know to talk about the project but
if you're asking them for money do in a
different platform or do it or don't do
it at all I mean let the other people
talk about you that's much more powerful
somebody talks about you so you have how
many days left in the campaign 13 13 13
okay yeah I think that's why I just
tweeted I bet oh I was 14 but oh it ends
at like 3 in the morning or something
right which it might as well be 13 yeah
so you're you're coming down the home
stretch what are some of the mistakes
that you've made and then what are some
of the things that worked that you know
you'll continue if you ever go back
again um I've been doing a lot of of
reading of people's um recommendations
and a lot of people have said that you
should email your uh social friends
before you start the campaign and ask
them to help you and I think that's a
really good idea and something we didn't
do right and like we said before not
having a lot of stuff prepared
beforehand just because of the time
crunch that we are under so we would
have loved to have had some video
updates sort of pre shot and edited and
ready to go um so that we could just
every Monday we do like a video from a
different person or whatever but um so
that that would be something next time
going into it if we have more time right
okay and uh do you find that a lot of
people get back to you uh if you send
emails no they don't it's really
surprising that no one gets back to you
so I don't know what that is interesting
okay um do or like oh friends I I mean
talking like newspapers trying to get uh
newspaper ads you know you give people
ideas do you want you could you could do
an article about this you could do an
article about that crowdfunding local
girl um horror movie small movie 50
other things and well there's a lot of
news in chica so they don't need your
ideas for
stories but we've we've gone we've gone
inside and and found someone who knows
someone so that we're trying that we're
trying that out for SL oh okay yeah I
think I think having making contacts
with uh with media Outlets beforehand
really would have been helpful to try to
sort of get some media exposure lined up
before the campaign right and it's how
many days total we chose 30 30 okay are
you happy with that amount or do you
wish you'd gone um I believe Kickstarter
when they say longer isn't better so and
it's so exhausting and such a huge
process I mean that 60-day campaign
looks like a nightmare to me so I
couldn't imag imagine yeah that's a long
time because it is a job and there's so
much momentum that you build I mean
we're right in the middle right now and
we're definitely seeing our schlump in
the middle that all Kickstarter
campaigns have you have a big um in the
beginning you have a a big exciting
shoot up and then again at the end you
have another one
so it's like a bell curve how would you
change the perks of Kickstarter well one
of the worst things that Kickstarter per
has and it's not the model that they
built but how people uh use it is that
you know if you pay 10 to 15 or maybe
$20 for a DVD on a store why are you
paying 30 for one in Kickstarter because
what because it's an indie project
because it's you know what's up with
that why the minimum amount just to
appear in the credits it's $10 or $5 for
a thank you it's like dude I
mean look at the market pre-sale if you
want but why people I mean why are you
making people pay more for and you know
if if you're if your target audience for
the kickstarter campaign or uh people
that is related to cool and new things
that's all right because you know it's
like an added value they're going to
they're not going to you know they're
going to spend it but for normal people
if you want to reach like a broad
audience yes pre-sale as as you were in
the market competing to other people and
other DVDs and other films uh and at the
same time uh perks you know they give
you a lot of work a lot of work uh and
if that's the only way to find your film
you're not going to find your film you
know for the C uh from from Strictly
crowdfunding like selling merchandise we
rise like
$50,000 half of that went to pay for the
stock of the things you know all the
t-shirts and the The Mailing and
everything else and the other half would
have gone to pay the guys that were
making packages for 5,000 people for 2
years so in the end there's no money for
the film you know we got the real money
from investment from from crowd
investment you know people found in the
internet that were you know buying a
percentage of the film but the rest was
just promotion which is great if you
take it that way it's like okay let's
promote the film let's going to sell
t-shirt because you know that's going to
be people wearing a message of the film
and telling about it but to get real
money out of that is difficult John how
often would you say that a filmmaker
reaches out to you with let's say 5 days
left in a crowdfunding
campaign and you want to help them so
you mean in terms of reach us out in in
what way you know like help my campaign
pretty much I get that once a week and I
ignore it you know it's like I don't
know if someone's just saying I ignore
and you know for better anyone who just
says oh John help me with my
crowdfunding campaign you know to me
it's like I don't have a relationship
with you you know you're reaching out to
me when you just want money or you want
my help getting you money it's like well
you haven't learned anything from any
lesson that I've ever taught you know
it's like why what is the point what is
the why would I engage with you at that
point you know if you want to engage
with me in advance of that in any way
shape or form even to ask me a question
on Twitter and seek my advice on
something or make a joke or somehow
involve me as a person great and then
you have a crowdfund campaign and you
say hey John could you do this because
we have a relationship sure but I don't
even keep track of how many people say
oh promote my this that or the other
thing and I don't have a relationship
with them and I ignore it and I feel
perfectly fine ignoring it because that
person hasn't made the effort to have a
relationship with me it's pretty easy to
have a relationship with me I have to
say you know I'm pretty busy and
sometimes it takes me some days to get
back to people and stuff and you know
but generally it's rare that I don't
within a couple of weeks respond to
everything so you know with that being
said if you haven't
tried then you're not really you know
you're not trying hard enough so is that
are those things that you would love to
tell them but either don't have the time
or though yeah I don't even bother at
that point it's like you know it's like
it's just it's not my job to tell
people that I'm not engaging with them
when they're asking me to help them make
money when they haven't engaged me
beforehand and because I say that all
the time to people so you obviously
haven't read my book and so if you
haven't read my book then why are you
asking me to help you so when my book is
so cheap and easily available you know
and uh even and generally if you ask me
for a free copy generally I'll give you
a free copy so um with that being
said it's interesting that you know
people need to remember
that you know that we're in an exchange
based economy or referral based economy
and that you know if you want to someone
to do something with you you have to
provide them value on some level you
know and I'm not saying that to be
selfish or you
know you know demanding or anything like
that but you have to start
practicing those muscles or exercise
those muscles in order to be successful
and the other thing is if you're coming
to me for help in the last 5 days of
your crowdfund campaign chances are
you're too late because and this is the
thing about crowdfund campaigns that
people don't understand the way you
structure your campaign is how you're
will largely determine how you're s
whether you're successful or not and
that goes in terms of how much you ask
for what your rewards are what your
positioning is what your call to action
is all of that which which is in the
structuring of the campaign will help
determine whether you're successful or
not so and that's why 5 days before the
end of the campaign is most likely too
late for any kind of help that I can
provide you know or I would want to
provide you
know Nicholas are you able to tell
people what the keys are to crowdfunding
or do you feel that I know we talked
earlier and you said really you can't
tell people how to do it you just know
how to do it yourself yes you know it's
like I think it's very personal and the
the key for our project you know I can
talk about what I think we did right and
and I know we did a lot of things that
were wrong and the good thing about
doing a threeyear campaign not a 30-day
or a 90-day campaign is that you can try
many different things and that's what we
did you know and many of them were huge
failur and and many of them were
successes uh what I think is I mean the
reason I think I you know it's very
difficult to advise on how to make a
crowdfunding campaign is because I don't
think people uh in something that is
related to film or art you know if
you're crowdfunding I don't know
something physical that you're are
selling is like you're selling a product
but if you're talking about uh something
Arty I think people gives you money not
because the project but because of you
something very personal you know it's
like I always say we've we've done two
films one of them is the cosm which is
you know science fiction film whatever
and the other thing is the story of
three guys you know three students
willing to make a film and how we told
that story over 3 years with videos and
the blog and you know everything we we
we spoke about is what made people
engage with us and and be willing to
give us money and if the project have
been about anything else it would have
been the same that's my guess I'm not
sure I might be wrong maybe everyone
loves space on the Space Race but you
know it's kind of I think it wasn't
about especially the film but the way we
talk about it uh so I guess it's it it's
you know the success of R will depend on
on the person behind and and how good
he's able to express himself and to
pitch in a way pitch the pr so people
are investing in you not sort of filmed
not your I guess some you know some of
them invested in the film itself and
actually there is people that doesn't
even know who's behind you know it
happened to us it's like okay the COS I
know the COS that project I don't who
you are oh okay I'm the director hello
uh but you know I think that comes after
it's like the first people that is going
to start talking about you it's going to
do it because they they like what you're
telling them or the way you're telling
them that I don't know I might be wrong
it's I think it's really difficult and
there's been like now everyone is doing
crowdfunding all the time with with a
thousand projects and not many of them
are are being s a success which is sad
but I think we are in the beginning of
something you know it's like something's
going to grow and and needs to adapt you
know I think we are living a pretty
pretty exciting time uh and that we have
given a huge opportunity as fil makers
to uh not only because we have a lot of
things that we we didn't have like 15
years ago that allow us us to make films
which is much cheaper and easier and and
all that but because we are in a in a
really in a change of model and and and
a change of of of how the industry works
you know at that point where where
everything changes which is what
happened you know when the sound uh came
to film or when the new Hollywood and
manle B arriv that they were you know
changing everything how how it worked
and and we're at that point now I mean
we are we are at one of those points
that where we are going to define the
next 20 or 30 years of film I think it's
pretty exciting to be there so related
to crowdfunding or creative Comm or new
distribution models or uh trans media uh
I think you know we need to to be
mistaken we need to just try things and
and for them to go wrong we need to have
a thousand uh failures in in
crowdfunding to get one success and see
and say okay that was the way way to go
or or you
know it's it's like when when when you
have a success in in anything you know
you have a film about magicians and then
you have 10 films about magicians uh so
because you know it's a bus and probably
the only success is going to be the
first one because it was the first one
and that's so we need to you know keep
doing things and and keep building and
discover what's coming next so I first
discovered your project for tiny a story
about living small um while I was on
Kickstarter and um tell us about how you
began the campaign I know you it was
December 2011 or so when you started it
or little B I think we started it sort
of late October and then ended December
15th was our last day okay so what types
of things were you doing ahead of time
to plan it because you've done a
beautiful job at at getting awareness
out about it I mean so many people just
they make a video they put it on
Kickstarter and then they are very
passive about it and it seems like you
were both very proactive about about it
what were your strategies either ahead
of time or while the campaign was in
motion well let right this because she's
The Mastermind the architect of the of
the kickstarter campaign I mean I think
one of the really lucky things about our
project is that we had um sort of the
tiny house Community there you know
ready to kind of help us get the word
out and in the tiny house Community you
know there's a really vibrant online
community of so many different blogs and
Facebook pages and things like that so I
think you know before we launched the
kickstarter campaign we really tried to
reach out to to editors of blogs and um
you know create personal relationships
with people that you know could help us
get the word out um and so that was that
was one of the ways that we did that and
then um also reaching out to you know
anyone else that we thought kind of had
a stake in the message that we're trying
to get out there so any kind of
environmental blog you know design blogs
architecture blogs um you know any any
other subject matter that was touched by
this story We reached out to and we did
a lot of um you know for film courage as
well we did a lot of kind of guest blogs
and you know making sure that we could
provide great photos and great content
to kind of offer to these people and say
you know this is the story that we have
going on use whatever you want you know
and help us kind of get the word out
there and I think that helps a lot we
got you know we ended up getting picked
up by I think o.com and you know Mother
Nature Network and a few bigger blogs
that really helped us Sund Dam's Channel
um blog and the kickstarter blog
actually was was was huge um so it it's
interesting Kickstarter itself is is a
platform for um Discovery I mean I think
you found out about us through kick
Kickstarter but it just by putting it on
Kickstarter we actually um a whole new
group of people became aware of the
project which was really exciting um but
I would definitely I guess ADV like if I
were to give advice to a a similar like
an you know another indie film that was
trying to raise money on Kickstarter I
would definitely suggest that um don't
do don't do it right off the bat you
know wait a little while um develop you
know your plan and make some connections
and then also get a lot of the U media
to accompany your your campaign like M
was saying with like great pictures and
and videos and um things like that
because it helps sell the story a lot
more and and plus if you um you know
show up basically with
some stuff that you can can show and
point to and say you know we've already
you know done this or um I don't know
you know it it helps people with
confidence knowing that it's going to
get made
and yeah and I think too the message
with you know Kickstarter it's it's not
necessarily so much you know asking for
money it's more about like look at this
great thing we're doing that you can be
a part of and so I think it's really
kind of tapping into that inspiration
factor and you know as much as people
can kind of do that I think it will be
successful well mhm one one last uh I
guess uh piece of advice probably
um is to so one thing that we did that
maybe I would do differently next time
is just our rewards you know we didn't
anticipate how many people would be
donating and so some of our rewards took
so much time or or energy to fulfill
that um you know and and for for us it
was okay because we were still
relatively small um project and campaign
but for some of the larger films out
there they you know they could find that
they spend hours you know just
fulfilling um days fulfilling
Kickstarter rewards you know so um it's
just something to to keep in mind for
filmmakers I think yeah that's a great
point and I'm wondering too when things
weren't maybe happening or maybe you
didn't have days like that but I know
for our campaign there were days where
it was just dead in the water and it's
like okay time's running out what did
you do to try to drum up noise about the
project I mean I think yeah whenever
there was sort of a lull it would be
like okay you know I remember before we
started the project or the the campaign
I wrote down a list of every single blog
or you know mailing list or newsletter
or personal contact I mean down to like
the colleges that we went to just like
the alumni networks I mean any any
community that I could think of to reach
out to and was kind of just crossing
them off the list so if you know
whenever we hit a la I was kind of like
okay so what new blog can I write and
you know helpful cuz my background is in
writing so it was easy for me to kind of
like figure out a new angle and and
write a blog but um you know it was kind
of just like okay what what else can I
put out there just to keep putting stuff
out yeah I think definitely the plan
about you know having a regular
um sort of schedule of of blogs so even
if we knew that in advance that there
would be four or five blogs that we're
already willing to either write about us
or let us do a guest um blog we would
you know say okay well can we do it this
day because we didn't want to have five
come out on one day and then have a week
where there wasn't any so we tried to
Pace
it yeah and I think you know it's
important to remember too that it's it's
great to you know start small I mean a
lot of the press coverage that we got
you know started off being really small
kind of local blogs and newsletters that
you know someone would see it and be
like oh that's cool and they write about
it for their thing and it kind of got
you know would the the reach became
greater and greater but we started
pretty small and I think you know it's
not like you need to have a contact with
the New York Times in order to you know
make a successful campaign you can you
can start with who you know sure what
about for people though that maybe
either aren't willing to write or aren't
a skilled writer such as yourself and a
lot of people approach us and I think
sometimes they're afraid because they
know people might read it and they don't
know if it'll come across correctly or
you know what would you say to someone
that it has that fear of writing we
dealt with so many people like that I
mean I would say that there's there
there's more ways than just words to
tell a story so I mean if someone's
really visual or you know maybe someone
could like do a cartoon or I don't know
I mean there's so many different ways to
get a message across that doesn't have
to necessarily be in the written word I
mean it could be music or you know just
really kind of using creativity to think
of different methods I mean if they're
filmmakers presumably they do video
blogs or something like that um but I
would also say that I think any film is
going to be enhanced by having a good
writer attached to it um so it's almost
worth I mean you know maybe they don't
have access to a wrer at the moment but
that's kind of something that I would
think about in advance is just like okay
well there's going to be a lot of things
that need to be written you know from
the script to blogs to um promotional
materials you know it's it's good to
have at least somebody you can rely on
if if you're not comfortable doing that
yeah and of your under 200 backwards it
was like what 9 196 or something like
that were they people that you knew were
they from your college or were they
family and friends or who were they I'd
say maybe like maybe 20 to 30% were
people that we knew you know either
friends who gave sort of like $10 a
piece or family members who were able to
give a little bit more um but I'd say I
mean a good bulk of the people who
donated I think were either part of the
tiny house Community or um were excited
for environmental reasons or it kind of
found us you know through one of those
blogs yeah I I mean I might even be kind
of a high estimate I it's hard to say
but maybe 20 to 30% of them maybe 20% of
the money I think might have been from
people know because people we knew um we
had a few large donations from you know
family or something like that but I I
don't know I mean I think I was
surprised at how many people we didn't
know you know honestly and I mean
strangers who were backing sort of
higher levels which I never expected you
know to have a stranger sort of back at
the $500 level or something like that
which yeah really it was really great
and and from all over the world
Australia lots of people from Europe and
um yeah it was it was nice and you know
the interesting thing is when we first
launched the kickstarter campaign that
was we had 300 fans on Facebook or
something like that and and just as a
gauge of we we were relatively still new
um as a project and and if we had even
waited 6 months from that point I think
it it would have been a different story
you know as far as we would had even
more people we didn't know you know um
cuz yeah it's all about I mean it's
amazing what you can do with the
internet do you think people realize how
hard crowdfunding is I mean Kickstarter
and indigogo they're such sexy sites and
they see these beautiful trailers do you
think people just think oh I'll just put
this up and then strangers from all over
the world will find my I think that's
exactly what people think and they're
wrong and a lot of those if people do
that then they you see a lot of things
that don't that don't make their goal
like what was it you found a great one
they had this great project that I I
backed and I tweeted about it and I went
back a couple days later and they didn't
have any more backers I went back a
couple weeks later and they didn't have
any more backers I was like that means
to me that they didn't even put in the
effort to con their friends into backing
their project which means that maybe
they should look into how crowdfunding
Works more and try again because it's
almost a full-time job yeah there a lot
of refreshing of the the web page this
is our second anyone else anyone else
yeah and uh our first one um was
definitely a full-time job and and so is
this one it's it's really hard and you
have to do a lot of research and you
have to do a lot of contacting people
and blogs and you know newspapers and
things that aren't ever going to contact
you back but you have to contact them
anyway and just in Cas just in case and
it's it's very difficult and you have to
have a a base to start with too um I
read somewhere that you know your number
of Facebook friends is directly
proportional to how well your
Kickstarter does and Facebook um is
definitely the number one source for our
pledges so attractive um since last year
Kickstarter put in a great new uh
dashboard and you can see where
everything's come from coming from so
that's a great time waster too because
you can look at that and be like oh you
know 37% from Twitter I I better tweet
more so right mostly it's just trying to
get the word out and trying to get
people to repost it retweet um and that
sort of thing because that's it's really
eyeballs getting eyeballs on the project
on the on the video because if they like
the video then then that's could push
them over and explaining to people that
even if you don't have money to pledge
which I totally understand sharing it is
worth something if you tweet it if you
Facebook it and then if you do that
again in a couple days that really helps
the people and uh I do that a lot with
projects that I'm I'm not going to back
all share them because I think they're
wonderful and I want them to happen so
and having new content to post so that
you not posting the same thing over and
over again really helps we were a little
pressed for time with this uh with this
one um we would have preferred to have
had a couple of different videos ready
to go so we could you know release them
uh we did a second video after with
Barry Boswick who's in the movie that
was that was a lot of fun um and we have
a couple written but uh you know it's
been hard to line people's schedules up
so it would have been nice um if we were
smart to to to plan more time yeah to
have had the whole campaign but we had
to pull the trigger because of the
timing of our of our first screening so
so what do you found has been the
biggest uh draw besides Facebook to
getting people that are outside your
Social Circle family and friends to
donate what's been the best approach
well for our last Kickstarter we were
very lucky to get a lot of blog
attention and that definitely was what
every time we we got we featured on a
new blog like boing boing or Nerdist
Oro Laughing Squid it would just it
would just surge because it was um it
was eyeballs on it that hadn't seen it
before and that people were excited
about the idea and it also had the uh
legitimacy of an outside Source saying
hey look at this thing as opposed to the
person themselves yeah right hey look at
me over here um so that really really
helped um and uh in terms of not having
the same sort of media attention having
Barry Boston
retweet and or he does not doesn't have
a Twitter but Facebooking sharing the
the video that he did really helped Neil
G shared it which was helpful um Simon
hellberg who's in the movie shared it
which is helpful and uh just having
anyone share it is helpful anyone with
reach we uh we had a a little article in
the Nerdist uh today and and there was a
definite little there's been a bump
today that that really went along with
that we were featured uh and we did an
interview on the Nerdist on Friday that
land that landed and uh and that gave us
a little bit of a bump as well so it's
it's just about getting the word out and
uh people people hearing your message
and hopefully liking what you have to
say well what sounds good in theory but
then it actually didn't work too
well huh
um well I'll look at the kickstarter and
oh gosh there hasn't been a pledge for 4
hours and I'll go and and do a lot of
social media and nothing happens so it's
really hard to know what does work
working yeah um what else doesn't
work uh what else doesn't work oh I sent
an email to every single person uh from
that is on my Facebook from my hometown
and I people just don't read Facebook
messages is part of it but I think I got
one
response so that you know people say
personal um appeals but I think emails
may be better than Facebook messages
right phone calls phone calls okay text
messages explaining to your grandmother
how to open her email so she can share
it with her friend right do you think
there are certain times of day that are
more receptive to tweets I mean I know
DAV has always said 5:00 seems like a
good time is that getting off and and I
noticed in the morning too um which is
terrible you have to get up in the
morning we like to work late yeah um
that's the problem too is a lot of times
3:00 a.m. I'm tweeting and Facebooking
up a storm and nobody cares sure well
there's people in Germany yes yes our
foreign fan Bas we have we have fans in
Indonesia so true that's true the film
is played there so John can you give us
a few reasons why people succeed at cop
fun
[Music]
um you know I'd say the easiest blanket
statement would be because they set up
their project properly you know and they
strategized it well and they you know it
and what people need to think about is
that crowdfunding is very much like
making a film you know that it's a lot
of prep you know and all the the more
work you do in the prep it's going to
benefit you in production that if you
Prep properly the production will be
much smoother and if you don't Prep
properly you're going to be scrambling
you know and then there's post you
there's the follow through so um you
know I think being realistic about who
your audience is and how much of an
audience you have and
making that you know sync with your goal
um and then also thinking about your
audience and potentially what they'd
want from you in terms of rewards and um
and providing
those in a create and providing creative
and interesting rewards you know having
a compelling um call to action and
compelling video and being personable
and and
um and and then you know working it or
you know having enough people on board
to help work it during the campaign you
know and that's you know what I would
say you know do you think people can
take their social media as a collective
of the project and kind of break it down
and say well I'm assuming if we have X
amount of Facebook followers x amount of
Twitter followers realistically we're
going to be able to get this much you
think that works I me I think you have
to be very pessimistic you know and
really look at um uh conventional online
conversion you know and online
conversion is you know at best 1% so you
know which is very so if you have 10,000
followers say which I almost do say so I
have 8,000 followers on Twitter and if I
convert 1% of those to even look at my
Kickstarter page right so what is 1% of
10,000 you know I'm a math guy so uh 10%
is 1,000 so 1% is 100 not much right so
if I get if I do a 1% conversion from my
followers so that's 100 and if I get 1%
of those people to then convert from the
conversion because the the first
conversion is the click the second
conversion is the buy that's one person
out of my 10,000 followers who are going
to contribute now I think I'm probably
going to do better than that but if I
really want to be
conservative that's what you're looking
at so yes you can use your followers but
you have to be very conservative about
what realistic about who you're going to
convert now I probably you know will
have a higher conversion rate because I
feel like you know I like to I feel like
I followed my
you know 8020 Rule and that you know I
feel like I provide a lot of value to my
followers and I think I've maybe
engendered Goodwill amongst them I like
to think um and so and I know there's
certain people that I can call on to act
you know and I've contributed to
campaigns Etc so you know I
think you know you have to so it's not
an easy calculation let me just put it
that way it's not just saying oh I have
8,000 people so 8,000 people will
contribute or 4,000 will contribute and
Kickstarter says the average is $70 so
then 4,000 * 70 is is $4,280 th000 so
I'm going to set my goal it I'm going to
be conservative and set my goal at
200,000 you know that's crazy town you
know you're not that's it's not going to
work like
that